c'est tout de suite au coup de gueule du
jour on va revenir sur un phénomène
encore illégal qui se répand de plus en
plus il s'agit de commerçants victime de
vol qui décide de diffuser des photos de
leur volur sur les réseaux sociaux et je
suis complètement pour voilà donc là
Gilles Verdez je sais ce qu'il en pense
donc on va encore avoir une le son de
voilà de droit de laxisme une FO non de
légalisme j'en a rien à [__] de ton
légalisme donc on va voir on va voir ce
que tu vas dire mais tu peux dire ce que
tu veux de toute façon je t'attendais
là-dessus j'ai fait cette émission juste
pour t'entendre là-dessusendus par vous
allez voir ce que fait verd quand il a
des voleurs qui vient voler dans son
magasin vous allez voir il lui disent e
vous avez oublié ça les gars merci pour
nous en parler on va recevoir Jérôme
Jean qui était déjà venu nous voir
j'aime beaucoup Jérôme qui est venu nous
voir il y a un an qui va nous raconter
tout ce qui lui est arrivé depuis son
passage sur notre plateau vous rappelez
de Jérôme Jean mis la photo on avait
donné bien entendu raison vous allez
voir tout ce qui lui est arrivé à cause
de de gens comme Gilles et Johann
souer soyer d'ailleurs qui a été victime
d'un vol il y a quelques jours il n'a
pas hésité à publier sur les réseaux et
je dis bravo Johann et je sais pas
combien on risque au niveau justice
làdessus quand on dit quand on dit un an
de prison avec brass électronique pour
avoir égorger un gars je pense pas qu'on
va prendre beaucoup pour avoir mis des
photos de de voleurs sur les réseaux
sociaux voilà donc je va vous dire à la
limite vaut mieux le faire mais bon faut
pas le faire mais il faut mieux le faire
toi tu vas nous dire quoi tu vas nous
dire expliquer pourquoi il faut pas
faire j'ai pas besoin de tes
explications pour moi il faut le faire
je vais te dire j'ai pas besoin de tes
explications pourries et de ta vie
pourrie à Paris
Ave
[Musique]
le vol à l'étalage c'est la htise de
nombreux commerçants ça arrive
régulièrement ouais ils ont pas peur de
la justice ceux qui font ça et il se
sentent intouchable alors pour tenter
d'endiguer ce phénomène ces commerçants
en colère n'hésitent pas aujourd'hui à
poster le visage de leur voleurs sur les
réseaux sociaux capturés grâce aux
caméras de vidéo surveillance si
quelqu'un connaît cette personne merci
de nous appeler au restaurant mais cette
pratique illégale punie d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 € d'amende
en vertu de la présomption d'innocence
et de la Protection de la Vie privée est
approuvé par certains Français je ne
vois même pas le problème d'afficher la
tête d'un voleur on s'en fout il a volé
c'est c'est de sa faute quel est le
problème alors de plus en plus de
commerçant victimes de vol diffusent les
photos de leurs voleurs sur Internet les
comprenez-vous je comprends voonà ça va
commencer à secouer là dans l'émission à
19h48 parce qu'on va avoir ça et après
on va voir dans les manifestations
antivax il y avait toute une frange
antisémite géraline maillet atelle été
trop loin c'est le titre qui a choisi la
rédaction vous direz la vérité il y aura
Gérard etpine le médecin au sandales qui
viendra vous voir flor Philippo que vous
connaissez et Béatrice Rosen ex collègue
à vous qui peut pas vous blirer euh et
on aura avec vous qui viendra vous
porter euh voilà secours Éric nollo qui
a décidé a énormément défendu sur les
réseaux qui sera là également donc voilà
vous aurez comme un voilà un soutien de
de poids avec Eric mais sachez que
Béatrice peut pas vous blirer merci
merci Jérôme merci d'être avec nous
Jérôme on se rappelle de votre histoire
euh est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler
de ce qui t arrivé il y a un an dans
votre magasin j'étais victime de vol
comme comme malheureusement beaucoup
commerçant français et puis et j'ai pris
l'initiative de diffuser les images de
vidéosurveillance des voleurs et grâce à
vous ça il s'est passé énormément de
choses dans ma fille depuis je vous
remercie et euh et puis je regrette pas
aujourd'hui c'est que voilà j'affirme au
effort et d'ailleurs comme on les a pas
retrouvé encore alors qu'on a identifié
le véhicule un des auteurs je persiste
et signes je rediffuse à nouveau les
images et et puis je suis pas le seul à
le faire parcean va nous raconter tout à
l'heure dans instant qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé donc depuis un an ben beaucoup de
choses c'estàd qu'à l'issu de
l'émission j'ai énormément des milliers
de témoignages de commerçants qui se
retrouvent dans dans ce combat on pense
à eux fort voilà des beaucoup de
messages de
soutien sympathique contrairement au
propos de Gill Verdes que j'ai
détesté mais que j'ai géré avec beaucoup
de calme ce jour-là je vous ai trouvé
détestable en fait je vous
DISI il parle de la dernière fois par de
la dernière
fois non mais j'ai bien entendu mais la
dernière fois derreis j'ai rien contre
vous monsieur écoutez alors mais vous me
chauffez le débat n'a même pas commencé
nor par con je chauffe pas je m'exprime
non mais il par de la dernière fois g
bah j'ai bien compris c'est pas débile
j'avais été
absolument je vous dis juste ch colère
la dernière fois j'étais calme là je le
suis moins vous êtes journaliste je
pense que il serait nécessaire d'ouvrir
un dictionnaire vous vous êtes permis de
me dire que j'étais un délinquant
ah
délinqu
aujourd'hui tous les commerçants qui
nous regardent sont des délinquants
quand ils diffusent les images vous êtes
allé trop loin je voulais vous le dire
c'est fait on passe à autre chose et
j'espère non on va pas passer à autre
chose on va continuer le débat si vous
voulez bien non mais jérô Jérôme dit ce
qu'il a dit en plus il a cour il a tout
à fait raison bien sûr de dire ça j'ai
aucun problème je donc pour vous pour
vous on va on va on va ouvrir le débat
dans un instant mais girérô moi je vous
dis et c'est c'est je devrais pas le
dire mais je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous je comprends pas en fait cette
loi qui dit qu'on n pas le droit de
mettre les vidéos de gars qui viennent
voler non mais mais on est où là
ici on pe plus on peut
plus toujour Prim
délinin
pour c'est une prime au délinquant quand
c'est gens qui squattent une maison on
leur donne on fait tout pour les
protéger une prime au voleurs aussi
qu'on les chope flagrantlit on fait tout
pour les protéger c'est insupport
réagissent il s'en prent la gueule qui
sur un voleur laiss la parole merci déjà
nos invités à nouveau ce que moi je veux
vous dire c'est que merci ce que je veux
vous dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a créé
un collectif grâce à votre émission qui
s'appelle ralvol vous le voyez juste
derrière on est sur Facebook Instagram
Twitter tous les jours monsieur Verdez
on a des commerçants qui nous appellent
mais là vous me cherchez vraiment là je
donne votre nom c'est pas méchant c'est
amical mais oui par qu' retient ton nom
tous les jours des commerçants nous
appellent ils ont porté plainte pour
certains de moins en moins la plainte
elle est classée sans suite par contre
le jour où moi je diffuse des images
bien sûr vous mêes tomber dessus on me
tra délinquant et vous avez d'ailleurs
traité l'ensemble du plateau de
délinquant je trouve que il faut pas
oublier l'origine de tout ça pourquoi
tous ces commerçants diffusent les image
parce que présomption d'innocence vous
avez raison mais il y a absence
totalement de décision pénale c'est pour
ça qu'ils le font les
comm regarde comment s'appelle r pass à
TPM je pense que je pense que Fatou va
rejoindre le
collectif on a lancé une pétition en
désaccord avec moi làdessus c'est
sûr on a lancé une pétition ce soir j'ai
pas expliqué ce qu'on avait mis de
signerait pas quand même bah attends
qu'il t'explique il a Fatou qui va la
signer j'espère j'ess de la convaincre
aujourd'hui ce qu'on aimerait c'est que
on autorise les commerçants pour être
commerçant il faut il y a vous faites un
certain nombre de démarches vous déposez
vous avez un registre du commerce voilà
on n'est pas commerçant en claquant des
doigts comme ça ce qu'on aimerait c'est
demander aux autorités que les
commerçants qui sont victimes de vol et
qui ont clairement les images des
voleurs puissent les diffuser sans être
inquiété on a mis une pétition en ligne
à 5 minutes avant de rentrer sur sur le
plateau j'aimerais que des millions et
des millions de commerçants la signne
parce qu'à l'issue de votre émission on
a eu 98 % de gens qui nous ont dit mais
vous avez 1000 fois raison sinon on fera
jamais la justice les 2 % C les poes de
G les Ch Johan vous avez été victime de
vol dans une de vos boutiques il y a
quelques jours euh qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé un couple monsieur madame tout le
monde la vidéo derrière est entré dans
dans notre boutique et après avoir
analysé je dirais comme des
professionnels euh l'angle de la caméra
la disposition de la caisse le
responsable qui était occupé à à
encaisser sont passés tout simplement à
l'action et la scène a duré peut-être 3
minutes ça a été très vite et ils sont
repartis avec une parc d'une certaine
valeur et encore une fois de
plus c'est c'est c'est la fois de trop
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on on est
démuni et déjà déjà que c'est compliqué
pour les commerçants en ce moment on le
sait c'est très très trs dur le commerce
c'est très dur en ce moment et en plus
si tu dois faire avec des gars qui te
volent et en plus que derrière on fait
rien et que si tu dis bah tiens j'ai la
photo du gars qui m'a qui m'a volé on te
tombe dessus c'est vrai que on sait pas
comment s'en sortir parce que en vrai on
va pas se mentir ces gars là aussi qui
volent un blouson un truc ils sont même
si on les même si on les attrape 48 heur
après ils sont
dehors jô je vous le dis he faut pas non
plus rêver non plus VO faut changer il
faut changer tout ça
sinon ça va se généraliser et un moment
ce qui va se passer c'est que les
commerçants ils vont se faire justice eu
même et il faut pas le faire et c'est
eux qui vont derrière avoir des des des
soucis parce que on les loupera pas je
vous dire mais regardez Cyril vous avez
diffusé les images les gens sont allés
voir sur les réseaux sociaux alors les
réseaux sociaux ça a des avantages et
des inconvénients grâce à ça mais on
pouvait les suivre quasiment à la trace
les voleurs on savait dans quelle
boutique ils étaient passés où ils
étaient allés parce que les gens V
témoigner en disant on vous a vu sur
TPMP ils sont là ils sont là ils sont là
là vous voyez les images de ce que
Johann a fait dans son magasin il y a
encore un commerçant qui vient de
diffuser des images ce soir sont les
mêmes voleurs c'est les mêmes vous
alleznareti prés d'inocence ouais alors
la question qu'on vous pose aussi chez
vous à 19h55 de plus en plus de
commerçants victimes de vol diffusent
les photos de leur voleurs sur Internet
les comprenez-vous oui oui oui oui oui
oui oui oui oui oui oui oui oui et le
nom qu'on attend tous oui Kelly moi
j'avais une question à vous poser c'est
parce que du coup là on on on crée une
pétition pour légiférer le fait de ichz
les gens sur les vitrines et du coup
vous incitez les commerçants à le faire
aussi je suis de votre côté il y a pas
de souci mais est-ce que vous avez déjà
vu un impact positif bah oui dit ça non
bah non parce que du coup les gars ne
sont pas condamnés et comme ils ont pas
été retrouvés mais quand même on arrive
àac y a un réel impact positif où c'est
juste le plaisir de se dire bon ben au
moins nous on aura fait ça de notre côté
on a d'autrre petites vengean est-ce que
vous avez eu un réel un réel retour
positif sur ces actionsl vous suive et
qu'on a envie de de suivre le projet
mais votre question est intéressante
c'est aussi un peu le le CR de ce soir
c'est c'est que là on a diffusé les
images donc on a des précisions on a des
informations bien souvent 9 fois sur 10
on arrive à avoir une identité ou alors
on arrive à voir un autre commerçant qui
vous dit je les ai vu dans ma boutique
on arrive à à à fournir des informations
à la police c'est ce qui s'est passé en
ce qui me concerne c'est eu qui n'en
font rien parce que c'est pas légal
c'est ça le problème non c'est pas ça
c'est que derrière il faut du temps je
pense dans ce pays il faut du temps il
faut du temps je sais pas si un jour je
sais pas si la justice parle à la à la
police et la police parle à la justice
moi personne n'est capable de me dire où
on est mon affaire je suis d'accord avec
vous Jérôme c'est c'est inadmissible je
suis désolé on en peut plus parce que
derrière ils ont été volés d'autres gens
voilà et c'est inadmissible et et
aujourd'hui on a on est on est dans un
monde où c'est le laxisme total
excusez-moi et Gill pourquoi je m'énerve
après toi c'est pas contre toi que je
m'énerve tu sais que je t'aime beaucoup
mais pour moi tu es le symbole de ce
laxisme et de cette France qui va dans
le mur et je te le dis et c'est pour ça
que je t'aime beaucoup mais je vais te
dire tu en fait tu es toujours du du
mauvais côté tu es toujours tu
symbolises la France du mauvais côté et
en ce moment et ben on le voit la la
France privilégie on le voit he regarde
le gars là qui a qui a égorgé un mec un
an de prison avec avec bracelet
électronique le me c'est quoi cette
connerie des mecs qui volent toute la
journée il restent 24 heures tu vois
bien que la police leur parle aux
policiers ils en peuvent plus de la
justice ils disent on a pas envie de
faire notre travail à quoi ça sert on va
se faire chier aller aller aller
poursuivre des mecs pour prendre des
risques on a une famille on a et on va
et derrière ils vont être d'orreur au
bout de bout de 48 he à quoi ça sert on
en a rien on s'en fout et tu es pour moi
le symbole de la France de l'échec
excuse-moi de te dire ça parce que moi
la France la France aujourd'hui elle est
en échec surtout sur le surtout sur le
plan sécuritaire et surtout sur le plan
de la justice et Gill tu es tu à chaque
fois tu te caches derrière les lois tu
te caches comme si tu te
caches tu te caches derrière les lois
non tu te caches derri lo parce que tu
vas dire oui légalement c'est pas
possible on parle pas de ça aujourd'hui
c'est un sentiment si les lois par en
fait on le voit bien aujourd'hui dans
cette émission chaque sujet qu'on fait
on voit qu'il y a il y a y a tout à
revoir aujourd'hui il y a tout à revoir
il y a un travail colossal à faire en
matière de justice et en matière de
peine je suis désolé aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu' il y a un problème on voit bien
que parfois il y a des peines qui sont
qui sont bien trop bien trop importantes
et parfois des peines sur des choses
importantes qui sont qui sont qui sont
qui sont qui sont minimes et toi
aujourd'hui tu es c'est bon c'est bon
merci c'est bon Valérie du pont Moretti
c'est bon euh merci euh non mais c'est
bon c'est bon
merci donc Gilles Verdez je te le dis
j'ai rien contre toi et tu sais que je
t'aime beaucoup mais pour moi quand je
te vois je vois l'échec voilà excuse-moi
heureusement vous m'aimez t'im oui mais
j'aime les gens qui on aime aussi les
gens qui sont en échec non mais non mais